All right. Lou Adler,
thank you so much
for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Hey, happy to be here.
Thank you very much, Michael.
Really, really happy
to have you here.
Best-selling author in Amazon,
"The Essential Guide to Hiring"
and "Hire with Your Head,"
and really a world expert
on what it means to do
intelligent hiring
and getting hired,
and performance-based hiring.
Lou, can you tell me
a little bit about --
a little bit about your background
and how did you even
get sucked into this incredible
industry of thinking about hiring?
Well, that’s really
a good question.
It’s really good for engineers too
because my background
is an engineer,
if you look at my background.
Okay.
Guides and control systems.
Got an MBA
in Finance and Accounting,
then started working
in manufacturing, logistics,
cost accounting, budgeting,
planning, host of different things.
Aerospace,
handheld consumer electronics
and automotive, a whole bit.
And the only reason I actually --
I was running a
manufacturing company.
It was 40 years ago.
Hated the boss.
I mean, I got pissed off
every single --
every other week
when he came down,
he and I just argued
and I quit every --
every other week,
I’d quit for a year.
Wow!
Finally quit.
Decided to become a recruiter.
And this is the interesting thing
as an engineering person,
especially with
manufacturing background.
I could see the hiring process
was just like making parts.
I didn’t care if it was
automotive parts or rocket ship.
Because I worked on
guiding systems.
Could it be assembly line?
It was automotive, components --
it’s just you have
to manage yields.
You have to understand
what’s the product.
You have to have a design spec.
You have to have manufacturing
process and you have to manage it
every step of the way from concept,
from even how you procure parts
to final inspection
and inspection in between.
Most people in hiring
don’t see it that way.
My background as a systems engineer
made it a little bit easier,
predicting in Finance
and Accounting, and I said,
"Hey, it’s more than
just making parts.
You have to control the cost.
You have to get --
influence people.
So, very unusual
background for hiring.
And then, I was also a recruiter.
I’ve probably recruited
because I’m --
I was in college,
part of a fraternity.
I was the recruiting guy.
-Of course.
- It was all did.
So, it’s like I was designed
to be a recruiting person.
I love it.
Lou, why is recruiting hard?
Why is hiring and getting hired
a puzzle that confuses everybody?
Well, it is a puzzle.
It’s a great, great question.
A puzzle, it’s because
it’s multi-dimensional.
It’s not one-dimensional,
two-dimensional, three --
it’s actually five
or six dimensions,
and just getting one
dimension right is hard.
On top of that,
you got human nature,
which is one of the dimensions.
People make decisions.
Candidates get nervous.
Hiring managers don’t know
what they’re looking for.
HR overwhelms them
with cost and budgets,
and compliance issues
that don’t help.
People think that the best people
are just going to apply
to a job posting
and go through
the demeaning process.
You got all these variables
that impact the decision itself.
And then, you got all you.
All the kids going to school,
getting engineering degrees.
I know for a fact
you’re not going to make
the decision alone.
You get an offer,
you’re going to ask
your friends and family,
- "Hey, is this a good job?"
- Of course.
And if you’re getting paid 5% less,
People are, "Oh, you're not taking
that stupid job, are you, Michael?
I mean, all these stupid reasons
that people take dumb decisions.
But that’s what happens.
Then you get older, you make
even dumber decisions.
And then, you make a bad
decision, you suck it up
and you kiss [expletive],
and all this stuff happens.
And then, if you get married
and your wife says
you got to make more money.
So, you take a stupid job
because of more money.
You know, all these stuff.
That’s why it’s hard.
Right. And why do you call
these dumb decisions?
So, what is it about these
decisions that you
don’t consider them intelligent
or performance-based?
Okay. So, let me go back 35 years.
- All right.
- This is --
-- a true story.
There was a guy named John Morgan.
I had a job offer for him
as a plant manager
in an electronics
manufacturing company.
The company at that time
was making high- definition displays,
at least at that time,
and they’re moving into --
the displays are really
becoming unusual.
Liquid crystal and other stuff.
I thought I had the job closed.
It was a good job
Probably, in today's dollars,
2020 dollars,
Probably $150K to $200K.
I would have gotten
a 30% fee for that.
So, good fee for me.
He was going to --
He told me on Monday
he was taking the offer.
On Wednesday,
he called me up and said,
"I’m not taking your offer.
I got a better offer."
And he told me why.
He said, "Well, better title,
closer to home, more money."
And then, I said,
"Well, tell me
a little bit about it."
And he told me the company,
told me the compensation,
told me everything
about it. I said,
"John, you just made
a long-term strategic decision
using short-term
tactical information.
That’s a dumb de --
No, I didn’t say to him
that was a dumb decision.
I was desperate.
That’s what I just came up with.
And he said,
"What are you talking about?
I said, "Everything you said
is about what you got
on the start date.
Start date is a compensation.
It was only like 3% to 5% more.
It was the title of the job,
better than the one he had.
The drive was 15 minutes closer.
I said, "John, what you do
for the next 2 to 3 years
will impact the rest of your life.
You’re going into
an industry that’s declining --"
whatever it was,
electronic assembly processes
that were outdated..
I said, "You’re going to be
going into this industry.
In 3 to 5 years when you come out,
you’ll be no better
than you are today.
So, you just put
a lid on your career."
On the other hand,
if you go to this other job
that are putting
state of-the-art displays,
they’re going overseas --
I know the title’s
a little bit less,
but you’re going to put
yourself in a better
career trajectory.
But how can you --
- and I’m looking at myself --
- Let me finish the story.
- Let me finish the story
because it's --
-  Go ahead. Yeah. I'm sorry.
- But it’s a good story.
He calls me the next day, he says,
"I’m taking your offer."
Nine months later,
he calls me back and said,
"Lou, best decision I ever made.
Best thing you’ve ever said to me
about making a strategic
career decision.
I’ve now been made VP Operations.
We’re making three
plants in China."
This was when China was expanding.
The idea, if you have to
make career decisions,
not day one decisions.
So, focus on --
decision-making is
what you’re going to
be doing in year one and beyond,
not what you get on the start date.
And all the people who
advise you will be focusing
on the start date.
What's your comp?
What’s your title?
Is it cool?
Is it this and that?
That’s the dumb decision
and all your advisers
will focus on the dumb decision stuff,
not the long-term career decision.
And that’s, if I have
any message to say,
just focus on what
you’re going to be doing
and becoming, not what
you get on the start date.
I think that’s incredible.
I was just taking
a fascinating class at the
Stanford Business School
with Professor Demarest.
He was the Head of Communications
for George Bush Sr.
during his presidency.
And the whole class was about
how strategy equals context
and how you --
when you're approaching a decision
and you have the facts
on the sheet of paper,
it seems like an easy decision,
but you’re missing
the most important factor,
which is the context
of the decision.
And what you’re describing
is exactly the same thing.
The context is the career.
It’s not this moment of time
and how much
you’re going to get today.
Well, let me give you
another story because
that’s what I do, tell --
When you're my age,
you tell stories.
I love stories. Yes.
So, I have an MBA from UCLA.
My first year, I became
a financial analyst.
I also had an engineering degree.
And I was at the
corporate headquarters
of the 35th largest company
in the country.
All I was doing was
showing the slides.
That’s all I was doing.
I was in an operations
review meeting.
The group president was there,
the chairman of the company,
the CFO and I was nervous as heck.
I was like 25. Nervous.
So full nervous.
I didn’t even want to say  a word.
I was even nervous
flipping the slides.
That’s what they did in those days.
I mean I was so nervous
being in front of all these
powerful people.
The CFO of this corporation
had a group president.
It was probably a $3 billion group.
And the CFO of the parent company
said to this group president,
he said, "Strategy drives tactics.
And I don’t care how good
the tactics you are,
your strategy sucks.
Get the [expletive]
out of this room,
and come back with
a good strategy, because
you’re wasting everybody’s time."
Wow!
And this is massive.
You’re 25 years old.
and hearing this comment
to a group president,
I was just blown away.
But it’s driven --
that was the idea of strate --
if you have the wrong strategy,
it doesn’t matter
what you’re doing.
You’re going to waste your time.
Now, we go back to hiring.
I believe too many people
have the wrong talent strategy.
They feel they can
weed out the weak
rather than attract the best.
And when you attract the best,
you have to nurture him.
You have to spend more time
with people, they have  understand
the job requirements.
When you weed out the weak,
they got to go through a funnel,
in an automated impersonal funnel
and endure the inhumanity
of applying for a job,
and then not being told
and all those other stuff.
So, it’s the fundamental
attracting strategy versus
a weed-out-the-weak strategy.
So, at the corporate level,
it’s a strategy problem.
At the individual level,
making a decision,
it’s also a strategy problem.
So then, tangibly,
looking at my generation --
and let’s look, for example,
at the engineering demographic,
people who are
coming out of college
with an engineering degree
and they’re faced
with an insurmountable
number of opportunities
ranging from start-ups
to corporates,
to financial institutions.
How do you go about making
a decision for yourself?
And how --?
And then, I’d like to flip
the conversation on how does
the hiring manager can look
at 22-year-old candidates
and determine whether they will be
a good fit for their company
with no previous experiences?
Well, that’s a great question.
And it’s --
So, I’m going to give you
my biased viewpoint.
Of course.
My first job as an engineer
was in a big corporation.
When I got my MBA,
it was still at a big corporation.
So, I learned how
big corporations function.
I learned how engineers
in big corporations function.
And my first manager,
a really cool manager --
it was an aerospace company
and I was a systems engineer
for a nuclear missile program.
And he said, "I don’t want you
to do any work," this 22 years old.
"I don’t what you to do any work."
I want you to answer
these two questions."
And he said, "Why does E = mc2
and why can’t you
push on a rope?"
I said, "I don’t need to go
to the meeting, but I know
the answer to both
of those questions."
He said, "No,
you don’t know the answer.
That’s why you have to --
I want you to meet everybody
in the company and I’ll take you
out to lunch on Thursday.
And we’ll discuss your
answers on Thursday."
So, this was four days.
All he said, "All I want you to do
is talk to everybody
and get the answers
to those two questions."
Wow!
Well, the idea that I got was that,
at a big company,
you had to have a good manager.
So, if you don’t have
a good manager,
it’s kind of you’re getting lost.
So, I always had
good managers to help
and mentor.
So, they help you.
But the idea was
the technology for engineer,
could've --  yeah,
it's important. But you can’t convince
other people, albeit,
by proving a technology.
You have to influence them
using different set of skills.
I don’t want to call them
soft skills.
They're non-technical skills.
How do you convince somebody
who has a point of view
that’s not the same
as what your point of view is?
That’s skill
and that’s what I learned.
I mean, I didn’t learn it.
I understood it
by the fourth day on the job,
because I had
to meet everybody.
It was 35 engineers.
Wow!
So, it was kind of interesting.
Now, let me kind of say
that story again
because this is as important
-- of making a choice.
I took this job.
I was going to engineering school
upstate New York.
I took the job
in Southern California
because on March of 1968
when I got my engineering degree
upstate New York, it was snowing.
I got a call from a company
in Southern California.
It was Vietnam.
He said, "Lou, I’d like to make
you an offer."
No interview.
"I’d like to make you an offer."
I was a pretty good engineer.
I said, "What’s the weather?"
That was my first question.
"What’s the weather?"
"72 degrees."
I said, "Well, are you getting
the foreman?"
He said, "Absolutely.
You’re going to work
on a nuclear guidance program
for a Minuteman missile."
I said, "Will I get
any relocation?"
He said, "Yes." And I had no money.
"How much?"
"$0.15 or $0.18 a mile."
I said, "When do I get that money?"
He said, "The day
after you started."
I said, "I’ll take that offer."
I mean, this was not real
rocket science offer,
but this was interesting.
When I got there --
And these are brilliant people
working on how to place
a nuclear missile
using 1968 technology
within 100 yards of downtown,
the enemy, Moscow in this case.
Sorry for anybody in Russia.
But that's what the plan was.
And they could do it.
The guys hated the job.
Hated the job.
I thought it was pretty cool.
22, it was pretty cool.
I said, "Why --"
as I got to know them
over the course of a year,
they had all worked
on the lunar landing project.
All of them.
- And they said, "We went --
- Wow!
five years, 24/7 doing
exactly the same work."
But because the mission
was important, they went all out.
Wow!
So, the work itself is important.
The team you’re
working with is important.
But the mission is
just as important.
If you’re doing something
that’s important,
not just for you
but for something else,
you just get totally motivated.
It’s not work.
It’s just an exciting venture.
That job was not
an exciting venture for me.
I’d had others that were.
But if you can
get the mission right,
boy, you’re in the game.
So, I don’t know if that’s
the answer to your question --
- but it's the stories I share.
- No, a hundred percent.
And now, looking over the years
as you’re becoming more and more
of an expert of hiring
and you’re seeing all these
different case studies
and you’re part of
these case studies,
do you observe any different trends
in the young demographic
on how we make --
how we make decisions
on which companies
we join or what
career paths we take?
Are there shifts
through generations?
Yeah, I think that
there definitely are.
And this is the problem.
I don’t think human nature --
I talk to guys
not necessarily your age,
but certainly young people,
frequently, mid-label people,
and older people.
I have not seen a change
in human nature
as a result of all
that’s going on here.
Smart people, smart people,
there were smart people
20, 30, 40 50 years ago.
So, that has not changed.
What happened
is the corporate world
has changed a little bit.
I think --
So, if I had to make advice,
I’d say, you know,
if you could get to a place
one to two, three years
where you’d really
put on some kind of
a rotation program
and really put in different series,
that’s invaluable --
that just takes your education
to another level.
Because now, you’ve seen how
all these different functions work
and how you’ve learned
how you can't push on a rope
and understanding that.
And I call them
the non-technical skills.
There’s an article
I wrote on LinkedIn.
It says, "The best technical skills
in the world are a waste of time
if you don’t have
a non-technical capability."
And I basically say
that people get hired
for their technical skills,
but they get fired for lack --
or they don’t get promoted
for their lack of ability to work
with people, managing projects,
keeping budgets,
making commitments.
And if you can’t put both
of them together, it’s going to --
you’re going to be disappointed.
You’ll wonder, "Why?
Why am I not getting ahead?
Why is this not happening?"
It’s the soft skills --
I hate to call the word soft
because it’s too important.
I call them non-technical skills.
But it’s that combination
of both of them.
If you get an opportunity to do
both of them, you’re in the game.
- If you don't get an opportunity --
- Of course.
And I think a start-up
could be interesting,
but you don’t get the foundation
of how to grow a company.
And that’s why I would be real
concerned about a start-up,
pure start-up. I just --
Listen, the executives
don’t know how to run a company
and you’re going to be in there
not knowing how to run a company.
You’re going to have a --
It might be an interesting
experience and a rocket ship ride,
but you’re not going to get the
foundation you need
- So you mean you're --
- So I would say --
worried about somebody
who has no experience
in the sort of the real,
real world or the corporate world
running into --
running a start-up
and being an executive of day one,
and being a leader of day one,
not having experienced
some of these ropes themselves.
But Lou. I also want to transfer
the conversation also
to, hopefully, one day,
sooner rather than later,
when I have my own venture
and I will hire people,
and I will need to know
what people do I hire,
and I will have to make
some decisions,
what are the key things
that I should keep in mind
in performance-based hiring
as you’ve written in your books?
Okay. So, here’s the --
It happened in a conversation
this morning with
a head of research
for a major search firm,
one of the top three
search firms in the world.
And now, we're talking about
diversity hiring.
How do really get --
hire diverse talent?
And I said, basically,
it’s at the job description level.
And I --
when I -- I want to go back
to my first search assignment,
which was 42 years ago. I knew
the president of the company.
The company was making automotive
components and no job description,
no list of --
Well, he did have a role at hand.
He needs someone probably 10 years'
experience and a degree,
this school, and this
kind of background.
I said, "You know, Mike,
that’s not a job description."
- "That’s a person description."
- Right.
A job doesn’t have experience.
A job doesn’t have skills.
A person has that.
Let’s put the job description
in the parking lot.
What does the person
need to do to be successful?
- Right.
- I asked that question.
He said, "He got to turn
around the plant."
I said, "Fine, let's walk
through the plant."
Spent an hour
walking through the plant.
Labor problems, logistics problems,
warehousing problems,
manufacturing process problems,
lack of control,
no quality control.
I mean, it was
just a terrible plant.
Looking at material
all over the plant floor,
I said, "This is a terrible plant.
We’ll get someone to fix it."
That was my first placement.
I have never used a job description
listing skills and
experience since then.
I always ask the hiring manager,
"What does the person
need to do to be successful."
Five or six performance objectives.
Build a team of accountants
to launch a new product.
Work with marketing
and product management
to develop a new system
that does A, B and C.
Put together a product roadmap
for the next three years
based on industry trends.
It’s stuff that people need to do.
So, if you don’t know that,
how can you possibly
assess a person?
When I interview candidates, I say,
"Hey, one of the big things
we have to do is put
a product roadmap together
that looks at this series
of economic considerations.
Have you ever done
something like that?
Walk me through it."
So, what I do is I define the job,
the series of performance
objectives, and I ask candidates
to tell me about work
they’ve done that’s most similar.
- And I look at the people
- Okay.
who’ve done the most
comparable work.
It doesn’t have to be identical,
just comparable
in decision-making complexity,
design, team, collaborative skills.
And then, I’m in the game.
That opens a pool to everybody.
And I tell job candidates
the same thing.
And is it still as
relevant today when --
and especially engineers
joining young companies.
The roles, while they may be
defined in the beginning,
they change very critically
and sporadically over time.
So, is that method of hiring
for specific performance type,
is that still relevant
to the very new --
Of course, yeah. Absolutely.
I’d love to hear people,
I said --
Michael, tell me about
your biggest project
you had at this company.
How did that change you over time?
How did you deal with that change?
What was the biggest
problem you faced?
gap you had to fill?
- Walk me through those things.
- Right.
So, I’m looking for the ability
to not only do the work,
but also to handle bigger projects.
I want to understand
how you did it.
So, absolutely.
You just got to understand
the environment.
- On the other hand,
- A hundred percent.
in the pace --
And  I look at company culture,
the biggest proxy’s
the rate of change.
I mean, if you’ve never been
through a rapid change --
like when I was in aerospace,
it was like pushing on the last
and nothing would change.
I’ve been at fast paced companies.
I was at the first handheld
calculator company.
That was every day we changed.
It was more fun
and that would have to be.
My best real-time job
was working as --
in the first handheld calculator --
They might even have one here.
- A hundred percent.
-  Just to give you, guys,
a sense of what a handheld
calculator was in 1972.
8K chip. 8K chip.
All it could do was multiply,
add and subtract.
Couldn’t divide because
it didn’t know how to round off.
- Oh, my god.
- We could not divide.
We got the 16K.
It could divide,
but it couldn’t round off.
Had to get the 32 --
I mean it was pretty bad.
But it was fun.
I was in this chip factory,
looking at buying them
and it was fun.
But it was weird.
Different world but same problems.
Lou, you're just fascinating.
Thank you again
for taking the time to do this.
I really appreciate it.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you
for three words
that you would use
to describe yourself.
Well, you actually asked me
that at the beginning of this
and I was supposed to say
but I’m actually
a pain in the ass.
So, that’s maybe four words.
But the point being is
don’t accept conventional wisdom.
If you’re --
And that’s why it’s hard
because you have
so many competing objectives.
So, if it’s a candidate --
you as a candidate,
you’ve been into an interview.
You just got to ask the manager,
"Hey, before we get into
my background in general,
can you just tell me
a couple of things
you need to get done in this job?
I’d like to give you examples
of work that I’ve done
that might be most related."
So, now you’re talking about
some real important stuff.
You just got to push
the envelope and not just
accept the fact that --
I guarantee, 99% of the people
who interview you don’t know
what they’re doing.
So, you have to take responsibility
to be interviewed accurately
yourself and make sure that job
is the right one for you.
And make the decision
based on where you’re going,
not where you’ve been.
Hopefully, that’s helpful.
Thanks, Michael.
I think that’s extremely relevant
to everything that -- you know,
that my friends
and I are going through.
And thank you for the advice.
Thank you for your time.
Lou, have a great, great day
and stay safe, and stay healthy.
You too. Thanks, guys.
Take care. Bye-bye.